c'est au bord de la RD 910 à la sortie
de Sorini sur ce terrain d'un ancien
restaurant désaffecté qui a été retrouvé
hier après-midi le cadavre d'une jeune
femme la brigade criminelle de la
gendarmerie de tour aurait retrouvé le
corps grâce au témoignage de deux
personnes les enquêteurs travailleraient
sur une affaire de disparition
inquiétante le corps retrouvé au fond de
ce puits pourrait être celui d'une
prostituée d'après nos informations la
mort pourrait remonter au mois de
février dernier à l'heure actuelle on ne
sait pas si la victime a été tuée sur
place ou si le corps a été amené à cet
endroit pour y être caché le parquet de
tour a été saisi de l'affaire mais le
procureur s'est refusé à livré toute
information